yes there's a lot of memes on this
channel you like you loose
it's about memes news it's about
reporting on memes meme review reviewing
memes but the finest of them all the
greatest the most grandiose of them all
if the PewDiePie means everybody that's
right I'm talking of course about
YouTube's favorite show flicks tape
can't fix his heart when the real damage
is on the inside
well clearly it takes a lot of effort to
get on the PewDiePie sub read everyone
so honestly don't even try it's
impossible not at the lot of day I love
how this rebound this flex mean I
rebounded everyone was like a mr. jet
transmitting oh why why are some
embarrassing back then if I just stole
it
that's right you can't steal what other
people steal from you you can't steal
from me and say that I'm stealing
disgusting I'm gonna report it to the
mean police if you guys don't watch out
Peter plug giving his last brofist
before ending the channel 20 how do I
even say that 2387 colorized more like
2019 Cola rice don't worry about it and
yes I know I look good as an anime
character haha see this is what I'm
telling you guys I've been trying to
tell you guys for so long yes my
girlfriend is mine fiance do I say
fiance my future wife is in fact
italiano this is how she talks to me
everything it is not that are very good
you need to get the more relaxed on this
video ask them to like it right now and
hit the belly button will eventually get
to that point in a relationship where
all she does is this and I'll know
exactly what she's talking about oh it's
one of these why am i wearing headphones
dan dancer can then why are you posting
here
you can't call something cancer if you
are at yourself you can't can we copy
strike the game theorist yes pewdiepie
our chairs do do that I'm not even upset
I'm actually more aroused very nice but
can you simultaneously whip and nae nae
mad Pat huh answer me that one can you
do this while simultaneously whipping
naming I'll be waiting for your response
Matt Pat is trying to kill the planet
everyone knows you can't charge that
much energy at once
can someone please make a better version
of boom boom oh my god this is why I
have my trusty and hang that all tangs
if a meme is too powerful it needs to be
destroyed
everyone common in so we can trick the
YouTube review people that this is a
family-friendly video everyone common
wow I really enjoyed watching this video
with my son we had a great time together
well actually we never had this much
quality time together
in fact I do love my son right now in
fact I might just love him a little bit
too much a bit Oh feast damn that looks
disgusting what are you cooking in your
pen you not clean it in between what is
all that white stuff dude disappoint it
disgusting repulsive but also but office
watching pirated movies be like
audio-video audio video video audio what
a bad mean if 2018 means can be
summarized it has to be with like just a
text over anything anything just put a
text over anything and it's a mean if
YouTube rewind doesn't feature text
layered memes I just realize that's the
way to kill a mean when was its featured
on YouTube rewind
hahaha it's this 15,000 people she was
just joking about being oppressed
outside it was just a joke wait for that
response by the way I'm anticipating it
guys obviously I don't want people to be
a press tight side I just said it
I had joke because I love being a press
outside by the way 15,000 people showed
up my name is Connor hey oh god it's
coming back it's back for vengeance well
I really need to play that game
but am I gonna but imma good I hope
there's some but am I gonna means in
there that would make me happy but then
again you guys aren't that creative what
if Peter Pyle played an uncut and
unedited version video and there was a
contest to see who would come up with
the best edit finally we have figured
out a way so I can replace Brad won and
Brad - I don't have to come up with my
original content great now I don't even
have to pay my editors anymore I can
just like Lance do it this is great I
really like this idea you said it first
let it be known that you said it first
Simon was always memeing you need to pay
me more boo boo boo boo boo oh yeah when
you start bullying children and become
leafy in order to avoid that was a
clever meme actually well done the joke
here is of course that I am leafy now I
mean I do look better there's no doubt
about it
I sort of understand leafy now they've
make big falls rows into a real thing
Walmart is that real that's awesome Dave
we're gonna be dying is granny a whole
night and see what developers are gonna
be working on for the next few months
including yes dragons in fortnight
[Music]
another one Dan see if I only if only I
invested in this meme stock I would be a
millionaire plus you know I could use
insider information because surely
somehow or I'm not taking credit okay
but surely if I review a meme there
should be some killing of that mean so
that I can sell off those memes does
this make any sense
[Music]
we didn't need the air repair but very
good at it by the way a lot of people to
put so much effort into these dumbass
things that's what makes a meme
beautiful well done Joe average two to
one whether she's a queen or a thought
if she had headphones aimed she's now
death or if she know how to properly
structure sentence she wouldn't be
parted Jesus Christ a lot of video memes
I like that keep the video memes coming
great job to whoever made this meme
are these all the memes I reviewed
- oh I see what you'd like to find out
that's supposed to be married set
yeah
[Music]
I'm never doing happy
that man needs to live forever he's far
too important
[Music]
Hey
oh come on what okay that was I was
getting into it can you make the whole
whole movie please just change the whole
plot well an article saying good things
about peace that's nice I did see that
thank you Frank here Oh namaste I think
it's the only one that really I've seen
would put emphasis on it I mean it's
like every article ever they mentioned
me and they bring up all my bad past but
they would never mention any of this
because it doesn't fit to portray me as
somewhat decent character
I bet piers gonna love this tattoo well
I like Batman so that's cool oh it's an
okay sign didn't look thank you very
much I will pee through it Thank You
Brett bus driver very cool dr. Phil I
call it content inator oh I'm sorry I
made three videos you're all a bunch of
crybabies way way way wink
I don't care I'm not like those other
youtubers who say they love their fans
superlame I say screw you fans thank you
epic games sob poops go to play four and
I said they made a custom banner for him
only he gets that if he ever placed is
that true because I did play for a
knight once and I thought it was
legitimately a fun cool game but my own
pride came in between that it was so
popular well they're doing fine without
me
I think they'll be all right oh that's
actually kind of nice don't make me feel
bad is it time it's a time for me to
play for at night it's a time for me to
bite the bullet and bite my pride and my
stubbornness making an hour-long video
of quality content making a 10-minute
minute video about important matters
making a 10 minute video about memes
making a 10 minute video about bean
memes but get bored in the middle and
just ask in practive to edit this out of
it and add a minute of peace with music
and a minute of
as commercial to get to the 10-minute
mark
Felix has really outdone himself this
tab this is not true okay you guys think
you know me
just because you presented through a
mean I mean I could just record an
hour-long video call it a Content but am
I gonna I don't think stuff I upload
every day I'm sorry sometimes I get
really busy with other stuff when life
comes up or whatever I have other
projects all that I'm working on in the
background and sometimes I'm sad to say
I don't have that much time to put on a
video eight years every single day eight
years eight years everybody I'm sorry
I'm sorry
now you apologize okay I said sorry you
say sorry is this an outro listen it's a
creative way to show the gameplay of
animals super squad as the greatest game
of all time check it out link
description and enjoy a is for any maybe
it's for my family friendly feeling geez
I said is for gameplay H is for I is for
intellectual J is for Jake Paul K is for
the whole alphabet
[Music]
why is free you laugh you loose Z is for
zero deaths yay that's awesome thank you
boring Boris for nine-year-olds oh
that's awesome now you guys know that is
so thoughtful what a thoughtful meme
everybody everyone go upload this when
you're so poor in real life that even
shadow rendering is set to low when
you're so poor in real life that you're
an overly expensive laptop everybody
while this meme made so much sense meme
correction do it right and do it again
okay maybe put a bag of Lidl with a
shadow on it or something
Jesus Christ y'all dumb that's it my
fellow nine-year-old that was it we did
it thank you guys for all the memes this
is really fun I really enjoyed it
if you had fun as well leaving like and
I'll see you guys tomorrow
good bye